are dr salvatore paeus's mind-blowing
patents merely a pathetic bluff to scare
off america's rivals what is your
response to that
absolutely not sir
they are not
a bluff
a lot of people have called them this
information
a lot of people have called them this
information but if you look closely the
physics is correct
all you have to do is look at it
dimensionally and you'll see that that
electromagnetic energy flux is the not
only the correct dimensions but has the
correct physics in it but you realize
that okay it is possible to get these
kind of energy densities not by just
having very high voltages
in that local area very high electrical
charges but also for example very high
frequencies of either vibrations or spin
now to go back to your question on james
sheehy because that's important i think
this one that's coming up go ahead sir
you're going to ask about dr james
sheehy yes he attested that it was
operable is that correct
these are the terms that he used and i'm
not quite sure exactly what he meant by
it but
if you look at the physics again these
are based on the laws of clocks
classical electromagnetism these
computers these devices this microphone
i'm using none of them would work if it
wasn't for the veracity the validity
of the heavyside version of
what we understand now is classical
electromagnetics
so yeah
[Music]
maybe this is what he meant was he able
to test it
none
how should i say
as far as i know there's no such craft
out there that's using the pius effect
that
we try to do what's called a high energy
electromagnetic field generator at pax
river we try to actually do the
experiments we try to accelerate the
charge
uh in spin
up to a hundred thousand rpm so we talk
about ten thousand radians per second
so quite high angular velocities but
uh
the charge that was used was could not
be achieved more than 10 to the minus
eight coulombs and you need at least a
one coulomb electrical charge to affect
some of these
more remarkable
phenomena